81 kg de bronze c'est ce qui a intéressé
les voleurs des revendeurs de métaux
intercepté lors d'un contrôle aléatoire
des douaniers au péage de gye près de
nancy début août une intervention
musclée
interception assez houleuse puisque les
les infracteurs ne se sent pas arrêtée
aux injonctions des douanes on a dû
les ans forcé le barrage et la voiture
n'a pu être
récupérez le la fourgonnette que
quelques kilomètres plus loin alors
qu'elle avait déjà un pneu crevé et les
occupants de la voiture s'était
volatilisé l'histoire se termine bien
puisque la statue est de retour à beaune
dans le parc de la bouzaize où elle a
succédé en 2006 salon dean d'auguste
préau elle faisait figure de petite
sirène son socle vide est un spectacle
désolant mais lena aurait pu ne jamais
être retrouvées les représentants des
douanes de la gendarmerie la galeriste
qui a été à l'origine de la commande de
l'oeuvre du sculpteur belge irene duriez
se sont réunis autour du maire alain
suguenot pour fêter cet épilogue heureux
c'est le symbole de la bouzaize symbole
des eaux-vives belena étant la source
des eau de bonnes donc quand boon était
plus connue pour ses hôtes pour son vin
et donc la revoir ici alors que l'on
pensait qu hélas elle était partie
peut-être en vacances mais peut-être
définitivement donc grâce aux douaniers
je tenais à remercier notamment les
données de meurthe-et-moselle et pour
éviter un nouveau vol un système de
sécurité est à l'étude il faudra
attendre encore pour voir bellina dans
le parc de la bouzaize